mein name ist willkommen wir heute zu
einem neuen video hier spielen heute für
meine damen und herren von tieren
handelt in sehr vielen haut teilte
haustiere sind sie werden gestreichelt
geliebt in diesen kämpfen sie allerdings
wir spielen bettelt kämpfende katzen ihr
findet schon hier oben irgendwo werbe
video eingeblendet das liegt einfach
daran weil mich der entwickler der app
gefragt hey you for the opportunity hier
klicken jetzt einfach mal auf play und
wen schon wir werden auf eine karte
gesetzt und sind in korea alles glaube
ich während kann ich mich normalerweise
eher weniger ich werde oft in der uni
gefragt was jetzt deine motivation hier
deine energie gerade für die vorleser
energie ist gerade -5 also auf jeden
fall sehr am start wir haben tatsächlich
sehr wenig energie gerade können aber
einfach jetzt mal beispielsweise
techniken und dann erklärt dass sie viel
geld von dem gegner und dafür beim
bürger und den wert besiegen würde schon
oben wir haben 100 cas quasi das neue
quartier ausgekoppelte mit künstlichkeit
und die qualitäten und an ich kann jetzt
auf level 1 klicken
das habe ich natürlich geld katzen
münzen oder irgend sowas zu zahlen und
jetzt habe ich quasi oben rechts mehr
geld zur verfügung das geht schneller
voran erntet jetzt noch zwei karten
gegeneinander kämpfen und hier unten
schon freier und wenn ich dann mal drauf
klickt werden die komplette tatsächlich
im moment angelangt wo meine karten
soweit forderten dafür jetzt die
jabü
ich habe gewonnen nämlich einfach schon
das spiel an sich und haben hier eine
welt und wir müssen die welt vom gegner
zerstören und was mich frei lassen
können hier wir können uns hier gerät
empfohlen wir können uns auch dann unser
geld was wir haben können wir
eintauschen gegen andere katzen und
können uns dann quasi wo auf dauer ein
richtig geiles im auto mitnehmen dann
gegen andere teams kämpfen wert laufen
wird quasi unser menü meditation werk
fertig gedrehte und die öffnet sich
jeden moment nämlich genau jetzt und
jetzt haben wir da drin ein item und
zwar gesundheit ist nicht nur weltweit
wir kriegen jetzt einfach mal drauf wenn
schon dass wir jetzt hier und wir gingen
auf travel time verteilt die bezahlung
war die 1500 damit wir elf von diesen
catcap sie uns öffnen können wir werden
jetzt alle gerade geöffnet meine damen
und herren und jetzt schauen wir mal was
wir da drin haben wir haben hier eine
knappe die auf einem ring herum hüpft
also einen der seltenen pokémon joji
kato liebe katze wtf freude wärmen
alter schwede
jurassic the hunted tts eine super
seltene badewannen für worldwide cat
nochmal eine die bekannte und noch mal
eine kokette wir können hier vorne lang
laufen hier durch afrika und wen schon
hier vorne dass sie hier war spanien
oder frankreich deutschland
wir greifen jetzt deutschland an
ich werde hier natürlich etwas kommt von
diesem kleinen katzen rausgekommen
natürlich nicht hier und sind relativ
schnell direkt beim gegner deutschland
wird als bier dargestellt wie jeden mal
direkt hier auf level 3 damit wir mit
mehr geld sammeln können ich will doch
gar nicht
die kleinen der einzigen gerade frage
für eine katze alter meine leute greifen
hier vorne sogar schon die welt von
deutschland sind auch schon relativ gut
mit am start
da kommt ihr alle noch was ist mithin
denn falsch gegangen alter relativ
schnell ging meine damen und herren
würde ich einfach mal sage ich dir
zurück wir gehen ins laptop weil die
impera of darkness jetzt wie ich mir
jedoch noch diesen drachen ihm einen weg
rein weil ich habe richtig bock sowie
die sache gleich den endgegner fernando
übrigens ganz große sache
deswegen werbe video stehen habe ich
gleich zu beginn schon gesagt aber wie
gesagt wo sich halt einfach vom
entwickler angeschrieben und er meinte
er wir können die mv zur verfügung
stellen und so weiter und so fort und du
machst im gegenzug video wer das nicht
mag
also ich meine nicht ganz cool game was
ich zocken kann und ich habe eine
kooperation also ich hoffe dass
gefährliche wenn dann könnt ihr schon
mal lassen und jetzt stehen wir die
letzte fällt hier vorne gebeugt alaska
hawaii und hält auch den montag jetzt
einfach mal ab und greifen jetzt
den mond an dass unsere welt vom gegner
kommen alle angelaufen wtf ich dachte
ich kann also schnell alles gut machen
aber auf jeden fall noch dran freuen am
ende werde ich den drachen hier unten
gleich aus wenn ich habe jetzt mal
einfach hier die wo alte rakete mit ihr
ab man voll krank wie auch mein geld
nach oben schnellt gerade breit ihr
bereit meine damen und herren für den
unglaublichen drachen ich werde ihn
jetzt game einwänden 5700 konnte der
unfall jetzt
von eva trautmann ich muss allerdings
sagen dass ich tatsächlich gerade nicht
so gut bin also ich meine die bake vom
gegner vor komplett heile und die ganzen
leute raus und ich verteidige gerade die
selber ein angebot
jetzt kann ich mal wieder aktivieren und
man hier unten habe ich jetzt
tatsächlich alles schon ausgesandt wir
warten jetzt einfach mal ab wie die
initiative mit den vorarbeiten update
vom gegner wird angegriffen meine damen
und herren alter geht die schnell runter
ich habe gerade noch für andere leute
empfand aber ich glaube hatten die
herforder sogar schon alleine die über
50.000 40.000 30.000 ich habe einfach
den musikvideo meine damen und herren
ich hoffe euch hat diese kooperation
gefallen ich hoffe euch das video wird
etwas getan hat las war leichter
außerdem findet am dritten august auf
der facebook seite dieser phase von
battle.net ein event statt wo man einen
speziellen charakter für das game
gewinnen kann also findet ein link zur
facebook seite in der beschreibung muss
man auf jeden fall ein absenken wird
mega krank war übrigens der spieler
selber spielen wollt findet ihr einen
link in der infobox eingeblendet werden
darauf hier könnt ihr euch das geld
nämlich einfach aus dem ios oder android
store herunterladen
dort findet ihr oben ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr da drauf klickt
könnte ihm einen kanal kostenlos
abonnieren das umfeld auch mein stopp
eingeblendet und hier unten ist ein
weiteres video verlinkt und schreibt wir
mal ob ich davon noch mehr videos machen
soll weil ich habe jetzt megageil team
aufgebaut und so und wir könnten alle